♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
BACK IN JANUARY WE FIRST
REPORTED ON THIS SHOW ABOUT WHAT
WE DESCRIBED THEN AS A SERIOUS
VIRAL OUTBREAK THAT APPEARED TO
BE RISING FROM A CITY CALLED
WUHAN IN EASTERN CHINA.
AT THE TIME THE OUTBREAK SOUNDED
OMINOUS AND POTENTIALLY
IMPORTANT BUT STILL VERY FAR
AWAY.
TODAY, LESS THAN TWO MONTHS
LATER THE CORONAVIRUS IS
OFFICIALLY A ENERGY HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THE PRESIDENT ANNOUNCED THIS
AFTERNOON IN THE ROSE GARDEN.
>> TO UNLEASH THE FULL POWER OF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT I’M
OFFICIALLY DECLARING A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY.
>> Tucker: THE PRESIDENT WENT ON
TO DESIGN MEASURES TO CHECK THE
SPREAD OF THE VIRUS AND TO HELP
THE COUNTRY RECOVER AND
CERTAINLY WEATHER THE ECONOMIC
DISRUPTION IT’S CAUSING.
THE PRESIDENT’S STATE OF
EMERGENCY DECLARATION FREE’S UP
$50 BILLION TO BATTLE THE
EPIDEMIC.
MOST VISITS TO NURSING HOMES
WILL BE SUSPENDED.
THE PRESIDENT ALSO ANNOUNCED A
TOTAL FREEZE ON INTEREST
PAYMENTS ON THE NATION’S
1.5 TRILLION IN FEDERAL STUDENT
LOANS.
NO MORE PAYMENTS FOR A WHILE.
HE SAID THE GOVERNMENT WILL
PURCHASE BILLIONS OF BARRELS OF
OIL FOR THE STRATEGIC PETROLEUM
RESERVE.
WE’RE GOING TO FILL IT TO THE
TOP, HE SAID.
THEN, IN RESPONSE TO INADEQUATE
TESTING ACROSS THE COUNTRY
SOMETHING THAT’S GOTTEN QUITE A
BIT OF ATTENTION HE ANNOUNCED A
NEW INITIATIVE TO OPEN
DRIVE-THRU TESTING FACILITIES.
>> THE GOAL IS FOR INDIVIDUALS
TO BE ABLE TO DRIVE UP AND BE
SWABBED WITHOUT HAVING TO LEAVE
YOUR CAR.
>> Tucker: WE WILL HAVE MORE ON
THE PROBLEMS WITH TESTING FOR
THE VIRUS IN JUST A MINUTE.
THE PRESIDENT’S ANNOUNCEMENT
TODAY SEEMED TO CALM MARKETS A
BIT AFTER DROPPING 10 POINTS
YESTERDAY, THE DOW JONES
INDUSTRIAL AVERAGE ROSE BY MORE
THAN 9% WITH MOST OF THE GAINS
COMING AFTER THE PRESIDENT
SPOKE.
STILL, ACROSS AMERICA, REGULAR
LIFE IS ALL BUT SUSPENDED RIGHT
NOW AS YOU KNOW WELL.
SPORTING EVENTS, CONCERTS AND
PLAYS ARE BEING CANCELLED SO ARE
RELIGIOUS CEREMONIES.
THE MORMON CHURCH STOPPED ALL
SERVICES WORLDWIDE.
AT THIS MOMENT THERE ARE ABOUT
2200 CONFIRMED CORONAVIRUS CASES
IN THE UNITED STATES.
THERE HAVE BEEN 48 DEATH.
THOSE ARE NOT HUGE NUMBERS IN A
COUNTRY OF 320 MILLION.
BUT THERE IS REASON TONIGHT TO
BELIEVE THIS COULD BE THE
BEGINNING OF SOMETHING BIGGER.
IN ILLUSTRATELYITALY ANOTHER 250
BIGGEST DAY YET.
PEOPLE ARE STARTING TO TAKE
DRAMATIC MEASURES.
MANY REMEMBER THE VALUE OF
HAVING BORDERS.
DENMARK, POLAND AND THE CZECH
REPUBLIC HAVE ALL CLOSED
THEMSELVES OFF FROM OUTSIDERS
AND NOT LIKELY TO BE THE LAST
COUNTRY TO DO IT.
IRAN, WHICH COULD BE THE COUNTRY